هذه واحدة من أكثر
الصور التي تم توقعها بشدة من
تلسكوب الفضاء على شبكة الإنترنت ، وأعني أنها لم
تخيب أمال تلك الصور من أعمدة
الخلق التي اشتهرت بواسطة
تلسكوب هابل الفضائي في عام 1995
، والآن قام ويب بتحويل عدسته.
نحوها ومنحنا هذا العرض
المذهل وهناك على شاشتك نوع من
المقارنة جنبًا إلى جنب على اليسار
والتي تم التقاطها بواسطة تلسكوب هابل ،
إنه تلسكوب بصري ،
لذلك يبدو في الواقع ما
يمكن لأعيننا أن تكون قادرة عليه  لنرى في الفضاء
ثم على اليمين يوجد تلسكوب الفضاء على شبكة الإنترنت
تلسكوب الأشعة تحت الحمراء ولذا
فهو قادر حقًا على النظر إلى تلك
السحب من الغاز والغبار بين النجوم
التي قد تبدو وكأنها تلك
التكوينات الصخرية ولكن
النجوم الحقيقية في  أظهر هنا الطفل
Stars Erica وأنت على حق ، فهم
لطيفون تمامًا لأن ما هو
أنيق حقًا هنا هو المكان الذي تولد فيه النجوم
الصغيرة ، وبالتالي فإن تلك البقع الحمراء الساطعة
هي في الواقع نجوم صغيرة
الخطوط الحمراء المتموجة هي بعض من إخراج
النجوم وأنت تعلم أن الكثير من
الناس لديهم آراء مختلفة ،
تعرف ما يبدو عليه هذا في الواقع كما
يقول بعض الناس إنهم يرون يد الله
تأتي المنتج لهذا العرض
ويقول إنه يرى  حصان راكض لا
أعرف عن ما تعتقد
أنه أراه ، أرى حصانًا أرى حصانًا
يمكنني أن أقتنع برؤية
الحصان ، نعم أنا أحب ذلك الآن أعرف
أن هناك شيئًا مثل  نجم صغير
ولكن أيضًا مدى تفصيل هذه
الصورة كان هابل لطيفًا كان لطيفًا هذا
رائعًا